(bright synthesizer music)
- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Abdullahi An-Na'im
who is the Charles Howard
Candler Professor of Law
at Emory University.
He is renowned for his scholarship
on human rights and Islam
and on human rights in
cross-cultural settings.
His most recent book
is Islam and the Secular State
negotiating the future of Shari'a.
He is on the Berkeley campus this semester
as the 2010 Tanner Professor.
Professor, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in a village
north of Khartoum, Sudan
on the Nile in 1946 and I
was raised in the village
and then followed my
father around various towns
in Northern Sudan going to school
and then University of
Khartoum, but I graduated 1970.
- And looking back, how do
you think your parents shaped
your thinking about the world?
- I think my mother did more
but my father also was--
both of them are very
committed to education.
But also, they were very open
in their lifestyle and their minds.
My mother never learned to read and write,
but she's one of the most
educated people I have known
in my life and my father also struggled,
was a self-educated man, so
I grew up valuing education
but also valuing the
need to be open to life
and possibilities and to other people.
I think that is how they raised us.
- And speaking of your
mother was she a product of
an oral tradition that made
her educated although not,
you know, with degrees so-to-speak.
- Yes, oral tradition
but also extremely smart.
I mean, she was a very intelligent woman.
She just grew up in Sudan
where women and girls
were not really allowed
to go to school much.
But now her daughters, she puts us
all through education and higher education
and her daughters also
now are all educated,
and I think, for me,
it is remarkable to see
in one generation how the possibilities
that were not very open to
my mum are now available
to my sisters and my children.
- Mm-hmm, and what...
Because your education was
into the ways of modernity.
You have PhD's and law degrees
in legal and philosophical studies,
what helps us understand their push
for you to be educated in a way
that went beyond the
traditional education.
- I think they helped me and my siblings
to be open and to be
willing to engage new ideas
and to be critical in our thinking.
I think their greatest
gift to me personally
is really to make me
able to take advantage
of the possibilities that I came to have.
Then I have to credit my other teachers,
my other father, my moral father,
Ustadh Mahmoud Mohamed Taha,
whom I got to know while I was
at the University of Khartoum as a student
and he also opened
tremendous possibilities.
I think, so I was fortunate.
And now I look back at
my sort of contemporaries
in the village throughout
education in Sudan
and I wonder where they are
and what they are thinking.
But I'm fortunate to be where I am
because of that gift I had.
- Mm-hmm, and what was,
we'll talk about your mentor
in a moment, but I am very curious as to
what are the elements
that made you comfortable
in pursuing, you know, an education
in the latter of modernity so-to-speak.
I mean, why did you
choose to become a lawyer?
- Of course.
So as far as I remember as a child
that's always what I wanted to be.
I never wanted to be a
doctor or an engineer.
To me, it was about justice
and being young and thinking
that you can bring justice to
people's lives through law.
So, a belief of the
fusion of law and justice
goes to my very early childhood
and also to the tradition
I grew up in where learning,
and learning the law,
is a means to achieve justice.
One of the gifts of my parents'
insights is about substance
in things, not the form.
So, they were religious and
they raised us to be religious
but to them being religious
is about the values
of being religious, not the
conformity with external piety
and ostentatious piety.
So, I think, that came
through with me about law,
about ideas as I came to always look for
what's the point here,
not what the form is.
- And is this a gift of being a Muslim
and the religious thinking
about issues in the tradition of Islam.
- It is that but also it's
about responsibility, I think.
Again, one of the aspect of
the gift is to be a Muslim
or to be a Christian or a Jew
or any religious affiliation
can be a blessing or a curse.
For me, my religion is what I make of it.
So, I'm not saved because I'm a Muslim,
it is what sort of Muslim
I am and what that means
in my life that makes a difference.
So, I think it is the ability
to work with the value
of religion without getting
sort of too bogged down
into the ritualistic formality of it.
- And in your writings which
we'll talk about in a minute,
I have the sense that part
of your self-realization
involving elements in your faith
that point in the direction
of self-development
even though they may be obscured
because of certain traditions
that developed in that religion.
- Yes, I think all
religions start that way.
I think in our personal life stories
or in the life of the tradition at large,
religions start about self-realization,
about self-liberation,
about responsibility,
about rejection of dogma.
But as they get attached to power
and as it becomes institutionalized
then I think the essence
of the religion is lost.
That's why we need to renew
religious traditions now
and again because they
get sort of too entangled
in threads of power relations
and privilege and so on.
So, I think the ability to discover
what the religion was about to begin with.
To me, the tradition,
it cannot be stagnate.
It has to be about
dynamism and self-renewal,
the tradition itself or else
it ceases to be a tradition.
It becomes a dead tradition.
If it's a living
tradition then the essence
of following the tradition
is to follow the innovative,
the creative, the sort of, what I call,
every religion needs its heretics.
For me, heresy is
critical to the viability
of religious experience
and the authenticity
of religious experience.
So, to keep the door open for heretics
is really a blessing for every religion.
- And was this an insight that
you learnt from your parents,
that is the way they saw the world?
- They wouldn't have
articulated it in so many words,
but the way they saw the world was a way
in which you seek the substance
and you don't get, sort of,
enslaved to the formality of it,
and therefore you are always
questioning whether this
is the right thing to do, not whether it
is the right thing that other people think
but what you think and
what you are responsible
for and so on.
- And let me understand as you...
Your education ends up in legal studies
but in your earlier education,
what were pieces of wisdom,
books, subjects that you pursued
that provided steps toward
your ultimate insights?
- To me, I think, in the Muslim tradition
the Sufi tradition is the best.
I mean, it is the most humane.
I call it the humane face of Islam.
It is the most profound.
So being exposed to Sufi
poetry, Sufi insights,
'cause they are really
about what the essence
of the spirituality is
rather than the formality
of religious dogma is.
So I think, for me, the Sufi tradition
in the Muslim experience
is very foundational.
But also I got exposed
to western philosophy.
I remember as a student
in, what you call then,
intermediate school which like,
sort of, high school level.
I loved to argue and I
remembered my teacher calling me
Socrates, I mean like,
he was sort of joking,
because I always-- especially
in the religious instruction class.
I was questioning and pushing
and so he called me that
in disapproval, like you are
argumentative, you are...
But I really...
Then I went to look and
see what is this man,
why am I called this and
so that was, I think,
all of that came together
for me and one thing
that I came to understand is that
as a human being I should remain open
to all human experience
and I should benefit
from all human experience, good and bad.
- A formative influence as you mentioned
was Mohammed Mohammed Taha.
- [Abdullahi] Mm-hmm.
- Tell us a little about who he was
and your first encounter, if not with him,
then what he was offering
in the way of a path.
- So, Mohammed Mohammed Taha
was actually a civil engineer
by training and by profession.
But he was a Sufi in orientation
and he self-embodied very much
the values I had been talking
about in terms of how
he's transformed himself
and realized from the mental
insights about what it means
to be human and to be Muslim and to submit
to the will of God and to live by that.
So, I had heard about
him long before I met him
the first time, and I remember
as a young man growing up
we were told beware, don't listen to him
because he's a spellbinder,
he will catch you
and you'll never escape.
But, by chance I happened to attend one
of his lectures when I was still
at the University of Khartoum,
a student in my second to third year--
- [Harry] You would've been about how old?
- Been about 18, 19.
19, I think, yes.
And I could never walk away.
I mean, I just heard that first lecture.
It was about the Islamic
constitution, yes and no.
So his argument was that
we need the constitution
to be about the substance of being Muslim
but never to be called
an Islamic constitution,
and again, order in Islamic state
as I came to argue in this book.
So, I listened.
I felt not only that he was talking to me,
but he was talking for me.
That everything he said
sounded to me like something
that I would have thought
or felt and wanted to say,
so I could never walk away.
So I started following
him around and going
to his other lectures.
He was an engineer but
also conducting sort
of this personal mission of propagating.
Very ingenious, I think.
Reformulation and
reinterpretation of Shari'a.
So I followed him and it was
a struggle because he was seen
to be a heretics, to be
an outsider and to me,
he was the best Muslim that can ever be
so I couldn't understand that.
So, I was lucky enough to
stick around long enough
to become one of his
students and to follow him
and to be a part of his movement.
- And what he was offering
for a young person such
as yourself is a path between
what was modern and what
was secular in a way,
but at the same time trying
to grapple with its relation
to the tradition and not
rejecting the tradition,
is that right?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- I think he helped me come
to peace with myself, I think.
Like, when I heard him and I read his work
I felt like being washed in
a sense of inner tranquility
and peace because as a young
man growing up I was committed
to values of human rights,
of constitutional governance,
of democratic governance,
but the tradition
of which I was part as a
Muslim growing up in Sudan
was antithetical to all of
that, and I couldn't understand
how Islam could be so negative
about women, about religious minorities,
freedom of religion.
By showing me that what
I rejected in Islam
was not really the essence of Islam,
but it was a human interpretation
that was contextually
historically conditioned.
And so, his basic message was
that we can only understand
and experience being religious
through our experience
in life, through our context, our history
and that we couldn't possibly repeat
or re-enact earlier
understandings of Islam
which Muslim accept as
Shari'a in the modern context
because that is not what the message
of Islam is for us today.
So, I think in that sense, yes.
He gave me sort of an inner sense,
sort of reconciliation,
two parts of myself.
The longing for the authenticity and depth
and emotional attachment of
tradition and the commitment
to contemporary values of human rights
and democratization and so on.
- And you actually
translated his scholarship
once you came to the west and so on.
I'm curious because you were a follower
and he was a charismatic
leader with substance.
How do you account for his insights?
Was it because he was a learned man,
because he was an engineer,
because he was a religious man,
all of the above?
I mean, what led him to this path
that helped you understand your path?
- I think very much the very fact that
as I have come to know in my life
that any of those gifts
can be an impediment.
I mean, the question is being
religious or being an engineer
or being a professional
man, being a educated man,
all of that could become a barrier
rather than a bridge to insight.
But I think his anchor, and the anchor
that I hope he had passed onto me
and other of his students
is that true spirituality
is not about power.
It's about renouncing power
and that is where you
gain a more sustainable
and more sort of self-renewing
power when you renounce it,
not when you invest in it.
So, his lifestyle that...
For me, what was most striking
about his ability to live
what he preached, and to
me that remains a test
for myself and anybody else.
So what extent do our actions reflect
the values we proclaim.
If they don't, then there's no value
in the values you proclaim.
So, it is the living flesh and blood
of being pious, not of
appearing to be pious
or putting on the semblance
of pious and so on.
- In your lecture you emphasize
the importance of changing
yourself so you can
change the world following
on the examples of Gandhi
and Martin Luther King
and others that you talked about
and I have the sense now
as I listen to you that
important in the struggle
is not an out rejection of any
of the traditions that
you're grappling with,
whether it's modernity and tradition,
so part of this self-development
is doing the hard work of
navigating between them
as opposed to rejecting that
one or another or embracing
one or another totally, is that fair?
- Yes, I think that's true.
To me, I call it mediation because it
is not a categorical resolution.
I'm not rejecting religion,
I'm not rejecting modernity,
I'm not accepting the sort of
perceived truth of religion
or modernity on face value.
So, to mediate is to sort
of travel between the two
and to bring a synthesis
within my own self,
my own consciousness and
experience and commitment
and practice by that synthesis,
and I think each of us have
to find her own or his own
sort of synthesis of tradition
or modernity of whatever
competing paradigms
that we live by.
And I think people like
Gandhi and Martin Luther King
have really done tremendously
in transforming the nature of power.
Power is part of life and
power struggles are part of--
we shouldn't be naive to
think we can have a powerless
or a conflict-free experience.
But the question is transform
the terms of the conflict
to make it non-violent and the notion
of force, not violence.
They are not naive, they were not naive,
they thought to affirm
but to transform the nature of power.
These ideas, I find them in my
own personal life day-by-day
and for me, I'm not
responsible for outcomes.
I'm responsible for what I do and say,
so to the extent that I live
what I preach to the best
of my ability and do my best
to transform my environment social
as well as material.
Then I have done my part.
I'm not responsible for the outcome.
- What happened to your
mentor, did he enter politics
and then what were the consequences?
- He was never in politics in
the sense of seeking power.
He started in the 1930s
when the Sudanese sort
of independence struggle
started establishing
a political party called
The Republican Party
because he was seeking to
establish a republic in Sudan,
a democratic republic in Sudan.
But, when in the 1960s,
the party was never going
to contest election, it was a vehicle
for promoting ideas about Islamic reform.
And in the 1960s when
political parties were banned
he transformed it into just
simply a social movement
or a religious intellectual
reformation movement,
and he continued to work
from the 50s into the 80s.
But he was political but not a politician,
so he engaged political issues of the day.
He had an opinion, a position
on every single issue that came along.
Eventually, of course, and he
was tolerated by various types
of so-called civilian and
military jibs in Sudan
until eventually it came to
head in the early 80s, 1980s,
when Numeiri who was the
dictator of the time,
he started as a military dictator,
transferred that into
a single party instead,
suddenly shifted to Islamic
fundamentalist ideology
and decided to impose
Shari'a as a state law
and Taha came out open
again as that charging it
as a distortion of Islam and a destruction
of the unity of the country.
For that single sheet of
paper, manifest or statement
he was put on trial for
political crimes of treason,
undermining the constitution,
nothing that really he did
was anything of that and he
was convicted and sentenced
to death and was executed in January 1985,
and I left Sudan in April
about three months after he was executed.
- And then you actually--
what was your next path?
In other words, you left your country
with a commitment to
advocacy so you wanted
to work at implementing
this heritage that you had?
- Yes, I thought it
was my personal charge.
I was fortunate because
I had an American friend
who was a professor at UCLA law school.
He invited me to come and to
teach at UCLA for two years
and at that time I
finished the translation
of The Second Message of Islam,
Ustazh Mohammed's main book,
had it published by Syracuse in 1987.
Ustazh Mohammed himself, in the early 80s,
before I left Sudan, one day
he just handed me that book
and he said, "Translate
this" and of course,
because of my training;
I had English, Arabic
and so I took it as a
personal charge to do that.
But then, for me, it
became, once he was executed
and the movement was
suppressed in Sudan I had
to leave, but thinking that my mission
is to bring his ideas to the world.
That, to make it that you cannot kill
an idea by killing its author.
So that was my mission and I kept watching
to see if things changing
Sudan so I could go back,
and for several years I
took short term appointments
in various places until the
early 90s when it looks like it
was not likely to be that
I can go back home soon,
I took a position as the
director of Africa Watch
based in Washington D.C.
- So, this is Human Rights Watch--
- Yes.
- Yes, it was a division
of Human Rights Watch.
It's called Africa Watch
at the time and then became
a division of Human Rights
Watch as a united organization,
and then in 1995 I went
to Emory to go back
to teaching in law school.
So, I have been teaching at
Emory law school since '95.
- Help us understand the skillset
that is necessary
because you're navigating
this world between tradition and modernity
but you're also becoming a lawyer,
and you are both a lawyer
and a legal philosopher,
and a philosopher about politics in Islam.
If students were watching
this, what are the elements
in managing all of these portfolios.
It sounds like there's both
an intellectual dimension,
a professional dimension but
also a psychological dimension.
- I hope there's all
that, but what I know is
that it's a personal quest.
I'm not really in this for achieving any
of those distinctions
or claims to expertise.
I'm just personally seeking
what I believe to be right
and to do what I think
is the right thing to do.
And I'm blessed and I'm
really privileged to be
an American citizen at this
point where I can pursue this
with vigor and with vitality
and to be able to reach.
You know, it is amazing
that having published
Ustazh Mohammed's book in
English and my own first book
in 1990 which is called
Toward the Islamic Reformation
in which I applied his ideas.
Those ideas were read more in English
than they could ever be read in Arabic.
So, although he wrote in
Arabic and my own native
language is Arabic, but English is spoken
by more Muslim's around
the world than Arabic is
and publishing in English
you reach more young people
and students and professionals
than you reach them
with writing Arabic which is
restricted also in Arab region
for censorship reasons.
Taha's books are not
available in the Arab world,
even in Sudan they are still banned.
But being able to translate
I could reach Muslim's
in Indonesia, Muslim's in Central Asia,
in Sub-Saharan, Africa and so what I see
is I'm just pursuing a way
of fulfilling what I believe
is my personal charge for which
I'm personally responsible.
Everything else is really
truly incidental to that.
- And in this mission there is
an important element of
both education and advocacy.
That is, to paraphrase what you just said,
in changing yourself you
wanna byproduct of that to be
in a position to help change
the world, is that fair?
- Yes, I think it's
fair but also to realize
that the most we can do
is to do the best we can.
As I said I'm not responsible for outcomes
but I am responsible for
trying to improve my way
of doing what I do.
To make it as persuasive and
as accessible as I can make it.
On my homepage I have this notion.
I think we have a website
about Islam and human rights
and we call it scholarship
for social change.
That is really the motto
I work with which is,
it has to be scholarship
for it to be useful.
So bad scholarship doesn't help any cause.
But, for me, scholar should
not be neutral in the sense
of being non-committal
about taking moral positions
and political positions.
I should invest in
investigating the issues
and vigorous scholarship.
But, ultimately, I have to take a position
and I have to defend that position
until I'm persuaded to change it.
So, for me, it is that pursuit of,
yes, I do believe in human
agency and I do believe
that all that is good
and bad happens through
the agency of human beings.
To me, God does not act in the world
except through human agency.
It is agency of human beings.
That is where our moral responsibility is.
- A critic of your work might say,
let me be the devil's advocate here,
that you are naive
in your work about power
and about interest groups.
If we look at the case of
your mentor, in other words
the end result was power said no,
and took his life.
So, help me understand the lever
by which you move beyond
just rejecting power and
make your ideas influential.
This obviously is a perennial problem,
namely theory and practice.
- [Abdullahi] Sure.
- And so, as we develop the best ideas,
and you are really doing
an important contribution
in that regard.
In the end, what is
involved in implementation?
- Mm-hmm, I call myself
a pragmatic optimist.
So, I'm optimistic in that
looking at the longer span
of history, and I see how great ideas came
to evolve and triumph over time.
I'm confident that human
rights, democratization,
Islamic reform will triumph over time.
It is the short term that
people have a hard time with,
and for me, that conviction of optimism
is really what is driving me.
But it is a pragmatic optimism,
it is not a naive optimism.
It's understanding the nature of power
but seeking to co-opt it,
and as I said about Gandhi,
seeking to transform it.
So, it is not a power-free
world but it is who has power
to what ends and, for
me, the fusion of power.
And education is key to the fusion
of the power of knowledge.
Religious education and
religious experience
is the fusion of religious authority
and so, to me, I say
that power and authority
is in the eyes of the beholder.
You have power over me to the
extent that I conceded to you.
But if I deny it there is
no way that you can get it,
so enhancing people's ability to hold on
to their own self-empowerment
and to refuse
to concede power to
others whether kinetics
or intellectual leads of whoever,
this is my most cherished
resource, my self-empowerment.
I refuse to concede it, end of story.
But it's not that easy, yes.
And therefore, I work
with political action,
I work with human rights advocacy.
I work with ideas to create conditions
where older people like myself don't have
to be exceptional like
Gandhi or Martin Luther King.
So I'm not a hero.
I don't want to be put
in prison or tortured.
That's why I invest in human rights.
So, I think honestly, I would say
that I am more pragmatic
than those who think
that they can impose the so-called notion
of imperialism.
Those who think they can
impose their values on others,
they are the naive ones.
I am the pragmatic one who
knows that it cannot be done.
- Let's talk a little about
Islam and the Secular State
and show your book, and some
very important ideas here
because what you are trying to do
is bring a perspective to Islam
and its dilemmas that it's not
that you're coming up with something new,
you're trying to articulate
a different tradition
within the tradition in order
to help Muslims deal with this dilemma
of modernity versus tradition
and so you have an important
point about the separation
of the state and Islam.
Explain that to us, because you believe
your faith is important in the context
of a separation but not a
separation of Islam from politics.
- [Abdullahi] Yes.
- Please, disentangle that for us.
- If I may actually, I would
like to read the first sentence
in the first chapter
because that is really key
to my whole approach.
In chapter one, the first sentence I say,
in order to be a Muslim by conviction
and free choice which is the
only way one can be a Muslim,
I need a seculary state.
So my claim is that a state that
is neutral regarding religious doctrine,
it does not take a position or religion,
is absolutely essential
for the possibility
of being religious because once a state
takes a doctrinal position in any religion
no matter how popular and
widely held that position is,
it is bound to be
oppressive of some believers
or others who do not agree with that.
So, I am opposed to totalitarian states
whether ideological or religious.
Second point, is that what
I am articulating, I think,
and I try to demonstrate in chapter two,
is in fact Muslim history.
That the notion of our
Islamic state is the heresy.
It is the new idea, it is
a postcolonial discourse
that throughout 1400
years of Muslim history
the state has never been Islamic.
It is in the postcolonial
context using a European idea
of the state and a European
idea of positive law
that Islamic's like
Maududi, for the first time
in the mid 20th century
articulated the notion
of an Islamic state to enforce
Shari'a as a state law.
So I am more with the tradition
in naming what we have lived with
as seculary states, not
religious states and they are,
I mean the Islamic's, are
the ones who are departing
from tradition by injecting,
mixing a European idea
of the state and as a
hierarchical centralized
political power with a
notion of positive law
to bring Shari'a into
enactment as a state law
is a negation of the
religious quality of Shari'a.
It ceases to be Shari'a by the very act
of enacting it as a state law.
But, then also I have to acknowledge
that Muslims have this
longing for their values
to be reflected in their politics
and by all means all societies do so.
The point for me is that the state
as an institution must be
separated from religion,
but politics is how people
behave and the choices they make,
so long as we can change our mind
about the politics we choose.
So, I emphasize
constitutionalism, human rights
and citizenship as the bulwark for,
what I call civic reason, which
is similar to Rawls notion
of public reason but different.
My notion is more inclusive than his
and I find it more broadly
acceptable to Muslims
because I'm saying you
can justify state policies
with reference to reasons
that all citizens can share
or debate without reference
to religious belief,
because if you say we have to
do this because God said so,
end of conversation.
But if you say I have to do this,
we should do this democratically
because of 1-2-3-4-5,
I can argue with you about
1-2-3-4-5, so that combination
of saying that in your
politics you can reflect
your religious values but
it has to be contested
and the constitutional
protection for everybody.
But institutionally, keep
the state out of religion
and keep religion out of the state.
- Let's go over this briefly
'cause I want our audience to be clear
about what you're saying.
So, in a way, the state is about power.
- [Abdullahi] Yeah.
- And about forcing people,
coercing people to do things
but it performs a function
which is to create a society
that is regulated so different religions
and different conversations
and dialogues can occur,
and in that world of society and politics
a person can be religious
and bring their faith
and their moral convictions
to the discussion.
But these two things in our
time have been conflated,
namely the notion that to
bring Islam to politics
and society you have to control the state.
- Yes.
- And you were rejecting that.
- Yeah.
- Now, what I'm curious
about is that has happened
in our time because of power.
You know, the power of
imperialism has brought changes
to the Muslim world
especially the Arab world
that has been rejected by
extremists within Islam.
So, I guess what I find intriguing
is there's a power game
here both, you know, coming
from the west in the form of
imperialism and the reaction,
you know, among Islamic extremists.
So, how does one win the dialogue?
How does one empower ideas such as yours
and Taba to have a voice in this struggle.
- I think it is already happening,
but it is just to be careful
and about how to do it
and how to do it more effectively.
The Islamic's, I call
them the fundamentalist,
really they are disingenuous in that they,
sort of, directorate is opposing the west
and imperial recent history
and new colonial history,
but their practice is
in fact co-opted a more,
taken by western institutions.
I mean, they do not
reject everything western.
They are very selective,
they keep the state which
is a western institution
so in the Muslim world,
in Africa and Asia,
the state was imperial.
It had very little to do...
So, in the precolonial
time there were states
but they were not centralized
institutional sort
of bureaucracies like the
European state has come to be.
So when the European
colonial administration,
British and French
brought this European idea
of the state and European
colonialism ended,
Muslim societies kept the
European idea of the state
as a totalitarian bound
centralized hierarchical
coercive political authority.
The most characteristically
European and colonial
of all political institutions, they kept.
But they want to inject into
it so they kept the shell
of a state and they
want to bring the values
and the institutions of a
previous era into that new shell
with which I mean, there
is incompatibility here.
So that is what I'm challenging.
I'm challenging to say
that since we have to live
with the postcolonial state
as that is the most viable
for the time being until we change it
through its own institutions over time,
if we decide to do that.
But since we have to live
with it we have to bring
in the safeguards that are more consistent
with the nature of the state.
So constitutional governance,
human rights protection
and the experiences of the same societies
that evolved these states had been found
to be extremely useful.
So, to go back to your
remarks, I agree completely.
I should have clarified
the state has limited
but very important
functions, but it is by far
from being the totality of
the public life of societies.
So the state should be kept
neutral for the purposes
of keeping the peace, of
adjudicating disputes,
of allocating resources and
mediating political conflicts.
That is what the state is for,
and defending the realm
against aggression,
that is the functions of the state.
But the rest of life in civil society,
in religious institutions,
in the universities, culture,
all of that is where
religion can be part of life
as it should be, I believe, as a Muslim,
but not to be in any way sort of co-opted
by the state or co-opting the state.
- You make a important distinction
in trying to reinforce
intellectually the separation
that the authority in
religion and in a state
are very different as is the
function of religious authority
and political authority and the state.
Talk a little about that
'cause it's very important.
They are two different kinds of authority
and when religious leaders
takeover the state,
which you are saying they shouldn't do,
then there is a corruption
of both kinds of authority.
- Yes, actually Iran today
is a very instructive example
of that confusion because the nature
of religious authority must be
spontaneous in the community.
That is, because it is premised
on a notion of piety
and religious knowledge,
that is very difficult
to quantify or to verify.
So, whom I trust to be my
religious spiritual leader
is someone that has to be my choice based
on my understanding of,
or knowledge of the person
and how his piety and honesty
and consistency and so on.
That sort of authority
is drastically different
from the nature of
political authority which
is inherently coercive and
which has to be something
that is the object of
a verifiable authority,
the ability of someone
to exercise authority
in a coercive fashion.
So confusing the two...
So what I'm saying is that the
nature of religious authority
and the nature of political authority
are fundamentally different.
So someone may have the charisma
and that person may endow
11 of this and the other,
but still they are different,
they are separate.
And this is not to say
that there's no politics
in religious institutions,
the Catholic church
or local community of Muslims
or a Jewish community.
There is politics everywhere
but the question is
that the nature of
religious authority must
be kept spontaneous, sort of voluntary
because to coerce someone,
to accept someone else's authority
is a negation of the
possibility of being religious.
So, Iran today, gives us a
very clear example of how,
when you think of the
supreme ruler or guardian
who is above the constitution,
but how does he get
to be there other than in politics.
So the very idea of a council of clerics
who politically get to
be at sort of the peak
of religious authority
is really a negation
of the nature of true religious piety.
- In your work you identify
traditions within Islam
that pose a problem for someone
who's western and modern.
The treatment of women, for
example, the relationship
of Muslims to non-Muslims
in other religious groups
and then the whole question of
jihad whether one implements
a jihad against the other.
Obviously, these three problematic areas
will arise in a realm of politics.
What is the key here because you say also
that the focus of your
life's work is really
to mediate universalism
in particular settings,
so particular settings,
cultures have to be respected
but the agenda is to bring citizenship,
human rights, constitutionalism
to these settings
and in the politics and
society you're gonna run up
against these problematic
areas, the treatment of women.
Talk a little about that,
what is the way out there?
- If I can put it this way.
To me, the notion of universal
human rights is a concept,
and a content, and a context.
So the concept is a concept of rights
of humans as humans everywhere.
The content, that is, what
are the specific rights
and sort of a list of
rights that we acknowledge
as human rights is a content
that is produced through
a consultation, consultative
consensus building process.
So, for me, the universality
of the content of,
say equality for women,
to me it is a human right.
But it is not a human right
because western society says so,
but because I believe Islam says so too.
And my charge is to articulate
that Islamic rationale
not only for myself but
also for other Muslims
who are more likely to be
persuaded if they see it
as an Islamic value than
if it is presented to them
as a western value they had to concede.
So, I say that universality
is not proclaimed.
It is constructed through dialogue,
and I use Rawls idea of
overlapping consensus to say
that we can agree on a set
of human rights norms despite
our disagreement as to why
we came to that conviction.
So as a Muslim I choose to
come to it from an Islamic
discourse, not denying
anybody else the right to come
to that conviction through
any other discourse
but claiming my right
to do so in my discourse
because as a matter of
principle that is a fulfillment
of my self-determination
as a person, as a community
but also practically it is more likely
to be persuasive to Muslim.
So the values that you mention
are the problematic aspects
which is about freedom of religion,
treatment of religious minorities, women,
equality for women.
To me, these are human
values, not western values,
and I do not accept that all
western societies subscribe
to these values.
After all, the holocaust
is a western phenomena.
Fascism is a western phenomena.
So, it is not as if the west
is enlightened, democratic,
humane and the rest of the
world is-- which was really
the logic of imperialism.
To say, that we are out to the
so-called white man's burden,
to civilize Africans by colonizing them.
That is the same logic, so I reject that.
I do not believe that human
rights can be advanced
by discourse that says they are western,
and in my charge is to make
them acceptable to Muslims.
My charge is to bring Muslim voices,
my own and others, into
debating what human rights
as a content mean.
And, yes, the context eventually
will come in to say even
if we subscribe to these
values, the way we translate
how they apply in practice
will also be a matter
of context and priorities and
Americans should understand
this because they refuse to
accept international supervision
of their human rights practice at home.
They say our constitution is
our ultimate sort of arbiter
of what rights are due to Americans
and by the same token other
people will have the same claim.
I think that many other
societies are willing to be part
of a global venture of human
rights universal standards
than Americans are.
So, come back to say the United
States is more relativist
just like China is
relativist, just like Iran
is relativist more than
many of the African
and other Asian countries
where Muslims are the majority.
- So, the agenda then for
scholarship, and your scholarship,
is to bring clarity and lucidity both
to what human rights are on the one hand
and what Islam is for Muslims
so it's a dual education process
which must be brought to mare not only
for Muslim communities
but also to the powerful
such as the United
States who basically say,
well, we're for universal rights,
we just don't abide by
them when we chose not to,
and you're saying the role of advocacy
is to be lucid for both settings.
- [Abdullahi] Yes, yeah.
- Basically.
Yes, I think you are right.
What I say is this, that the process
of building consensus
around humans rights norms
and their institutions is dual.
It is what I call internal discourse
to transform cultural understandings,
a religious understanding
within Muslim communities.
That's an internal discourse.
Then I call cross-cultural dialogue,
but my approach is premise on
the ability and willingness
of other human rights
advocates in other societies
to do their internal discourse so that,
if you see, for example,
the United States,
and let's compare it to
another country rather
than a religion or religious Islam.
Say, United States and Egypt
or United States and Turkey.
American human rights
advocates should be grappling
with human rights issues
that are problematic
to Americans, not to others,
and equality for women
is still is a problem for many Americans.
The question of the death
penalty maybe, the question of,
whatever the issue,
economic and social rights,
a right to healthcare,
a right to education.
Other societies take this as human rights.
Americans are not willing to do that.
So I would say that charge
American human rights advocates
to struggle just to get a
feel of how difficult it is
to transform attitudes
within your own society.
The death penalty is a good example.
See those who have struggled
to abolish the death penalty
and how hard it has been to
understand how difficult it is
for others to do the
same in their societies.
But assuming that both
sides of us are doing this
then we can engage in what I
call cross-cultural dialogue
to promote consensus.
So it is not that I'm
assuming that Muslim societies
will come to the table just fully closed
with their own convictions and no change.
But know that there are
human rights activists,
there are freedom of religion
activists who are struggling
in those societies.
Now, about imperialism, if
I may close with this point
is that imperialism
makes it very difficult
for human rights advocates
to struggle for the rule
of law in international
relations and they struggle
for human rights in their societies.
That, for me, as a Muslim I would say
the United States behavior should not
be my standard so that
I should be committed
to these values regardless
of what the west does
or does not do.
But the reality is that many
people in my communities
will say why should we
abide by these standards
if the United States is not
willing to abide by them.
So that double standard issue, sort of,
therefore when I say that
imperial impulse of United States
like invading Iraq or engaging in sort
of imperial ventures, that undermines
the very possibility of international law.
I want to challenge jihad,
Muslim sort of understanding
of aggressive jihad, as
contrary to the rule of law
and contrary to civilized behavior,
but it's very difficult to do that
when people feel under
attack by a super power
that appropriate the
right to act unilaterally,
arbitrarily outside
international institutions
and expect others to abide
by those institutions.
- The short term problem seems
to be power and the abuse of power.
The long term solution is
people changing themselves
and changing their world.
Briefly, one last question,
time is just about up,
for a brief answer.
How would you advise students
to prepare for navigating this?
In our discussion you have
described what chasing the flame
and keeping the flame
alive was for you because
of your parents and also
because of your mentor, Taba.
What advice for students?
- Keep it personal.
I think so long as when we
think that we are solving
the world's problems but not our own,
I think we are missing the point.
Only for me, as far as what
message I would like to bring
is keep it personal, keep it immediate
because I tend to avoid
responsibility if I can,
I tend to evade questions if I can.
So keep my feet to the fire,
understand that I have a
very limited span of life
in which I am supposed to heal
my inner self into one being
so that when I depart, I
depart whole and not divided.
I don't have time to waste
and I would say for everybody,
find your cause, find your
issue but keep it personal
and give it the best you can.
- Abdullahi, thank you.
That was a great discussion.
Let me show your book one more
time and I wanna thank you
for coming to the Berkeley
campus and being on our program.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- Thank you, and thank you
very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(bright synthesizer music)